[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
no
all right
the welcome host was absent no one to
tell the newest spawn what to do
or what it was
nostril gaia had become slightly
unwelcoming to new heroes
and those who assist them
[Music]
[Music]
the would-be hero began to suspect that
perhaps it wasn't loved
the confused stick figure would find no
answers in the narrator's library a
spreading pixelization had twisted
everything and everyone into retro decay
uh
nostalgia's memories had flattened like
books without pages oh
how the narrator moaned
pixels with a problem
what was this peculiar stick figure and
had it even noticed how retro everything
was becoming of course not it was made
out of pixels it was part of the problem
the narrator decided to make some
story edits
suddenly an ambush caught the hero
unprepared
you know what i think
i think the world is sick and you're
like the final pixelated tuber the
narrator vowed to save the world the
narrator vowed to cut you from it
suddenly a simple sentry transformed
into an impossible adversary one written
to crush the stick figure on site
um
[Music]
[Music]
ah
a beacon
a conduit through which heroes once
communed with nostalgia
upon it
[Music]
[Music]
by the almighty
impossible
you're
you're
what in the void are you
oh
you don't know what you are or why
you're here
do you want me to guide you
you are
no hero and i am no travel brochure now
i have no idea what your little gestures
were meant to convey probably rude but i
will tell you what you are
proof that nostalgia is dying
[Music]
so
[Music]
you are not worthy
no
the hero was rejected
no
the spinach had a final form of final
fall
[Music]
so
and so the stick figure proved it's in
it
the audacity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
the spinach had a final form up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you